lo que quiero abordar en este vídeo es
un caso especial de la regla del hopital
que es un un caso más restringido de la
de la regla en general que ya habíamos
visto
regla d
el hospital y tiene este acento gracioso
típico del francés y entonces decíamos
que vamos a hacer un caso especial un
caso especial de la forma general que ya
teníamos y la razón por la cual nos
vamos a enfocar o vamos a ir encima de
este caso es porque su demostración es
muy directa y te dará mucha inclusión de
porque la regla del hopital funciona
entonces vamos a partir con estas
siguientes hipótesis donde efe a una
función f evaluado en un punto es 0 y
además vamos a pedirle que su derivada
exista o no que sea igual que exista
existe muy bien y vamos a pedir también
una función g
una función g que evaluado en el mismo
punto a sea 0 y que también su derivada
evaluada en a exista
existe entonces si todas estas restringe
restricciones porque al final de cuentas
este caso especial es justamente
especial porque tiene más restricciones
está restringido a estas a estas
condiciones si tenemos eso entonces
podemos concluir que el límite el límite
cuando x tiende al punto a d
vamos a ponerlo así f x
sobre
gx perdón sobre gx va a ser igual
también a un cociente y de hecho por eso
le pedimos que existiera va a ser el
cociente entre f prima de a y que prima
de a ok entonces esto va a ser muy
sencillo de demostrar por eso es que
vamos a utilizar este caso especial y de
hecho vamos a partir de este lado
derecho para llegar al lado izquierdo
como vamos a empezar pues partiendo de
la definición de lo que es una derivada
y recordemos entonces que f prima
evaluado en a no es otra cosa más que el
límite el límite cuando x se aproxima de
fx
- efe de a sobre x menos a y sólo a modo
de recuerdo esto a final de cuentas lo
que me está dando es una aproximación
dependiente es verdad de la pendiente de
la gráfica la pendiente perdón de la
recta tangente a la gráfica de una
función por ejemplo si aquí está mi
gráfica de la función y aquí tengo el
punto
y coma efe de ok y aquí tengo el punto x
fx entonces lo que me está calculando
este cociente es la pendiente de esta
recta que aproxima que conecta estos dos
puntos por supuesto que si estamos
aproximando a equis o más bien x lo
estamos aproximando a esto cada vez se
va apareciendo más a la pendiente de la
recta tangente muy bien y ahora si
dividimos todo esto entre eje de prima
de a
si dividimos todo entre primavera pues
será dividir esto entre el límite cuando
x se aproxima deje x - g de a sobre x
menos a
y esto es el cociente que tenemos que
calcular verdad y por supuesto como
tenemos el cociente de los dos límites
que tienden al mismo lugar esto es lo
mismo que el límite esto es lo mismo que
el límite cuando x tiende a de estos
cocientes verdad de fx
a ponerlo así fx - efe de a sobre x
menos a y abajo vamos a poner solo gdx
menos idea sobre x menos a entonces para
simplificar esta expresión lo que vamos
a hacer es multiplicar arriba y abajo
por x menos a aunque entonces hacemos
esta multiplicación y lo que queda aquí
es que x menos a entre x menos a esto se
cancelan y éste se cancela con este de
acá abajo entonces al final lo que me
queda es simplemente el límite cuando x
se aproxima de fx menos
efe y quizás ya te está valiendo hacia
dónde vamos a llegar pero voy a dejarlo
con el mismo color para que no haya
ningún problema
fx menos efe
todo esto sobre gx
gx - cda y esto es muy sencillo ya ya
prácticamente estamos aquí porque ahora
tomamos la hipótesis inicial que de
fedea y gba son 0 es decir en a se
anulan ok entonces 100 ac anulan estos
dos valen 0 valen 0 y sólo me queda
entonces el límite el límite cuando
extiende a de fx fx acá arriba sobre
sobre qué de equis
así que acabamos de mostrar que si las
dos funciones
efe se anulan en el punto a es decir
valen cero en y que además sus derivadas
en el punto a existen pudimos demostrar
que el cociente de estas derivadas es
igual al límite cuando x se aproximada
de las funciones
efe sobre g de la función f sobre que
así que es una prueba muy directa para
este caso especial de lo que es la regla
del hopital